اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نساعد ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات
وفي العناوين
[موسيقى]
اوديستا تحت القصف الروسي وبيلاروسيا
تتسلم اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه من موسكو
[تصفيق]
يعتبر محاكمته محاوله لسرقه الانتخابات
المقبله ويتهم بايدن بالفساد
في تواصل امريكي الصيني حذر بكين تحمر
واشنطن مسؤوليه تدهور العلاقات
قتلاني وجريح في اليابان واطلاق نار في
ميدان رمايه للجيش والسلطات تفتح تحقيقا
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في تطور اللهفت اعلن
رئيس بيلاروسيا الكسندر لوكيشنكو ان بلاده
بدات تسلم اسلحه النوويه تكتيكيه من روسيا
في تصريحات للاعلام الروسي روسيا لم تسع
الى وضع صواريخها
بين العكس مشيرا الى ان هي التي طلبت ذلك
اولا وكانت روسيا وبيلاروسيا مشاهدينا
اتفقتا على نشر صواريخ
ومقاتلات على حمل القنابل النوويه
التكتيكيه ميدانيا المشاهدين اعلنت
الاداره العسكريه في اوديسا مقتدى ثلاثه
اشخاص واصابه 13 اخرين في قصف صاروخي
وذكرت في بيان لها ان القتل الثلاثه
موظفنا في مستودع تجاري اصيب بصاروخ كروز
روسي من نوع كاليبر واضافت الاداره
العسكريه لاوديسيا ان الهجوم دمر مستودعات
مساحتها 1000 متر وسبب حريقا على مساحه
400 متر مربع وفي نوفاكا خوف كمشاهدينا
اتهمت اداره المحليه الموا روسيا القوات
الاوكرانيه بقصف مناطق سكنيه ما ادى
لاصابه ثلاثه اشخاص وقالت في بيان الله ان
اوكرانيا لم تتوقف عن قصف المدينه رغم
استمرار عمليه الاجلاء بعد تدمير سد نوفا
واشارت ايضا الى ان سبعه الاف ومئتي تم
اجلاؤهم من المناطق التي غامرتها
الفيضانات
مساعدات امريكا العسكريه لاوكرانيا تدفعها
لعمق الصراع هذا ما اكده سفير روسيا لدى
الولايات المتحده انطولي انتونال حيث قال
ان حزمه المساعده العسكريه الامريكيه
الجديده الاوكرانيه التي تبلغ قيمتها
مليون دولار تدفع واشنطن بصوره اكبر الى
عمق الازمه الاوكرانيه وقال انتونوف من
الاستراتيجيين في الولايات المتحده لا
يفهمون بشكل او باخر انه لن يكون بمقدور
اي كميه من الاسلحه تغيير مسائل العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه على حد وصفه
مشاهدينا من موسكو على مراسله العربيه
اهلا بك عبد الجواد اذن تصريحات مثيره
وخطيره جدا من الرئيسه بيلاروسي لوكاشينكو
حول نشر الاسلحه النوويه في بلاد اسلحه
الروسيه بطبيعه الحال اطلعنا عليها رجاء
عبد الجواد
صباح الخير احمد نعم صحيح ما تقول هي
تصريحات من العيار الثقيل خاصه ان الكسندر
لوكاشنكا الرئيس البيلاروسي راح يتحدث
بلغه الارقام بان ما تم نشره ويتم نشره
على الاراضي البيلاروسيه
قوه هذه افضل القنابل او هذه الصواريخ
تفوق يعني قوه ما تم استخدامه في هيروشيما
ونجازاكي بثلاث مرات ما يعني ان لوكاشنكا
يتحدث بلغه الارقام عن اعداد من قد يصاب
يطالهم هذه يعني الخطر في حال تم استخدام
هذه الضربات تحدثت بانه في اليابان في
لحظه استخدام الضربه قتل قرابه 80 الف
شخصا ومئتين وخمسين الفا حيال الضربه بشكل
كلي لكن ما تم نشره في بيلاروسيا قد يودي
بحياه مليون شخص في ضربه واحده هذا ما
تحدث عنه
للجمهوريه حيث تحتدم المنافسه مشاهدينا
بين مرشح المعارضه والتيار الوطني الحر
الوزير السابق جهاد الزعور وكذلك مرشح
الثنائي حزب الله وحركه امل الوزير السابق
سليمان الى تفاصيل هذه الجلسه
ما لم يكن حائزا على الشروط التي تؤهله
للنيابه وغير المانعه لاهليه الترشيح
كما انه لا يجوز انتخاب القضاه وموظفي
الفئه الاولى وما يعادلها في جميع
الادارات العامه والمؤسسات العامه وسائر
الاشخاص المعنويين في القانون العام مده
قيامهم بوظيفتهم وخلال السنتين اللتين
تليان تاريخ استقالاتهم وانقطاعهم فعليا
عن وظيفتهم او تاريخ حالتهم على التقاعد
مده 75 من الدستور ان المجلس الملتئم
لانتخابي رئيس الجمهوريه يعتبر هيئه
انتخابيه لهيئه اجتماعيه ويترتب عليه
الشروع حالا في انتخاب رئيس الدوله دون
مناقشه او اي عمل اخر
من النظام الداخلي تجري جميع عمليات
الانتخاب في المجلس بالاقتراع السري
بواسطه ظرف خاص واوراق نموذجيه بيضاء تحمل
كلاهما ختم المجلس توزع على النواب وكل
ظرف يتضمن اكثر من ورقه واحده او يحمل
علامه علامه فارقه يعتبر لاغيا مده 12 لا
تدخل في حساب الاغلبيه في اي انتخاب يجريه
المجلس الاوراق البيضاء او الملغات تعتبر
ملغاتا كل ورقه تتضمن اسماء يفوق عددها
المراكز المحدده في النهايه
لبدء جلسه البرلمان اللبناني للانتخاب
رئيس
للجمهوريه في لبنان حيث تحتدم المنافسه
كما ذكرنا بين مرشح المعارضه والتيار
الوطني الحر الوزير السابق جهاد الزعور
وكذلك مرشح ثنائي حزب الله وحركه الامل
الوزير السابق سليمان افرنجي
خلال هذه النشره ونشاط لتفاصيل هذه الجلسه
نعود الى الملف الروسيه الاوكراني هناك
اوضاع انسانيه صعبه يعاني منها سكان
المناطق التي اجتاحتها السير في خرسون
نتيجه تفجير سد ومحطه نوفا مواطن نقدتهم
الظروف الى الاقامه في غرف المرضى
بالمستشفيات رغم انهم ليسوا بمرضى واخرون
اتخذوا من المدارس ودور الثقافه
احدهم متى وكيف تنتهي هذه الكارثه المشهد
رصده موفد العربيه الى خرسون حذيفه عهد
نتابع نحن هنا في مستشفى خرسون حيث
المعاناه اكبر عند اصحاب الامراض المزمنه
وكبار السن الذين فتح مستشفى خرسون ابوابه
لاستقبال النازحين منهم ومن تم اجلائهم من
مناطق الفيضان ممن يحتاجون الرعايه الصحيه
وحتى اولئك الذين لا يحتاجون اليها ولكنهم
لا يجدون مسكنا فقد تم اسكانهم بشكل مؤقت
في عنابر المستشفى حتى تجد السلطات حلولا
لاوضاعهم
في الوقت الحالي في القطاع يوجد 51 شخصا
منهم من يحتاج الى رعايه الصحيه هنا يوجد
من تم تنويمهم وفي الطوابق الاعلى يوجد
اشخاص لا يحتاجون الى الرعايه تم تسكينهم
ولكن على الرغم من ذلك اذا كانت لديهم اي
شكوى كارتفاع الضغط او الصداع نقدم لهم
المساعده تحدثنا الى بعض المواطنين
المقيمين في المستشفى كالجده الله التي
فقدت زوجها منذ اعوام وتعيش وحيده غبرت
المياه منزلها بالكامل واتلفت الاثاث
وجميع ممتلكاتها ولا تدري ما حل بالمنزل
بعد ان تم اجلائها
في الصباح استيقظنا على سياح رجل كان يصرخ
اخرج سنساعدكم لان المياه اتيه منك خفقه
وستغرقون
بدات عمليه الاجلاء وانا معاق لذلك قررت
الانتظار لم اكن اعتقد ان المياه يمكنها
الوصول الى هذا الارتفاع ولكن اضطررت الى
الاتصال بجارتي التي طلبت الدفاع المدني
والذين اتوا واخرجوني بصعوبه
الفيضان اغرق مساحات واسعه حيث لا تزال 46
بلده مغموره بالمياه معظمها في الضفه
اليمنى حيث سيطره الاوكرانيين والبقيه في
مناطق سيطره الروس الا ان المعاناه واحده
فقد الناس حياتهم وممتلكاتهم واصبحوا
نازحين يعيشون على الاعانات الانسانيه
تداعيات الكارثه البيئيه لا يمكن التنبؤ
بها ومصير الاف البيوت وممتلكات الناس ما
زال مجهولا وتحذر السلطات من دخول مناطق
الفيضان حتى بعد انحسار المياه خوفا من
الالغام التي غطاها الطنيو واصبح من الصعب
الكشف عنها ولا احد يتحدث عن عوده قريبه
لمن اجبرهم الفيضان على نزوح عادل العربيه
من مدينه خرسون
ومشاهدينا نعود مره اخرى الى موسكو
ومراسله العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد اهلا بك
عبد اياد من جديد هو نعود الى مقاطع من
حديث حول تصريحات الرئيس السبيل الرئيسي
حول مدى خطوره هذه الاسلحه النوويه
الروسيه التي نشرت في بلادها
احمد يعني رغم حديث الكسندر لوكيشنكو عن
لغه الارقام واعداد القتلى التي قد تنتج
عن هذه الضربات لكنه تحدث عن ان نشر هذا
السلاح النووي جاء بعد الحاح من قبل مينسك
على موسكو هذه الاسلحه التي نشر البعض
منها ويتم نشرها في القريب العاجل تحدث
لوكيشنكه بان الاماكن التي يعني تمركزت
بها هي مختلفه في الاراضي البيلاروسيه
راحت الكثير من المقالات السياسيه في
البلاد تتحدث بان بيلاروسيا اليوم اصبحت
دوله نوويه دون اعلان رسمي بوجود مثل هذه
الاسلحه هناك وهو يعني التي قد يمكنها
توجيه ضربات للعدو كما يتحدث الجانب
البيلاروسي هي ضربات تكون للردع فقط لكن
يعني في هذه المقالات السياسيه التي يتحدث
عنها احمد دار الحديث عن ان يعني طموح
الغرب في محاوله اقتحام الاراضي
البيلاروسيه
وصولا الى مينسك ومن ثم شمالينز ونهايه
بيمسكو هو محور واحد تم الان قطعه حسب
الراي الدائره السياسيه في روسيا بما يخص
نشر هذه الاسلحه طبعا الاسلحه هي لا تكمن
على الضربات الكثير من انظمه الدفاع الجوي
ايضا يتم نشرها هناك لحمايه المنطقه حمايه
هذا الوضع النووي الجديد بالاضافه الى عشر
مقاتلات من طراز سو خمسه وعشرون تم
تعديلها احمد حسب الروايه الروسيه لتتمكن
من حمل الصواريخ نوويه قد تستخدم في
عمليات في حال الحاجه للردع حول هذا
الموضوع الموضوع يكبر بشكل كبير بداوا
بوتين يوم امس احمد بالحديث عن ان موسكو
ستذهب نحو استخدام يعني الضربات
اليورانيوم المنظف في حال قامت باستخدام
هذا الشيء انهاه اليوم الرئيس السابق في
البلاد وسكرتير مجلس الامن الروسي نائبه
تحدث عن ان موسكو قد تذهب نحو تفجير
وتعطيل كابلات الاتصالات يعني خطوط
الاتصالات الغربيه في قاع المحيط قد تذهب
موسكو لفعل هذا كرد فعلي على دخول الغرب
في قضيه الضرب انابيب
لذلك الوضع ان يتشعب بشكل كبير بما يخص
المنعطف الخطر بينما المعارك ما زالت
جاريه في الجنوب شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه
المعلومات وتفاصيل
تهمه وجهتها محكمه فيدراليه امريكيه الى
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب في قضيه
الوثائق السريه بفم مطبق وحاجبين مخطبين
وكثفين محنيين بعض الشيء وذراعين تاره
مبسوطين واخرى مكتوفتين امضا بجلسه محاكمه
تاريخيه اصبح معها اول رئيس امريكي سابق
يمثل امام محكمه فيدراليه في قاعه المحكمه
مشاهدينا في ميامي حضرت مرتديا كعادته
بدله داكنه وربطه عنق حمراء وانسطها لكل
من القاضي والمدعي العام بصمت مطبق لم
يخلقه سوى ليحمس بضع كلمات في اذن محامي
وعلى الرغم من ان قط العقارات السابقه
الطعام حي العوده الى البيت الابيض في
انتخابات العام المقبل ملاحق بقضاء عديده
الا ان هذه الدعوه هي الاخطر على الاطلاق
هو تفاصيل المشاهدين حول محاكمه ترامب
وردود الافعال وسيناريوهات المحتمله نذهب
الى السفيه الزميل فارس الصلواتي الى كف
اهلا احمد وكما قلت العديد من الاسئله
تطرح حول مستقبل ترامبا السياسي وامكانيه
ترشحه من وراء القطبان في حال ادانته وهذا
بعد مثوله لاول مره امام محكمه فيدراليه
على خلفيه تهمى من جنائيه سابقه في
تاريخها سياسه الامريكيه ترامب اكد ان
خوضه للسباقه الرئاسي حتى في المنعطفات
الاكثر خطوره فبعد مثوله للمحاكمه التي
تضمنت توجيها 37 تهمه جنائيه وفيدراليه
بينها سبع تهم تتعلق بالاحتفاظ غير
القانوني بمعلومات تتعلق بالامن القومي
والتامر لعرقله العداله قال انه غير مذنب
ونفى كل التهم الموجهه اليه واشار الى انه
ضحيه لمقاضاه انتقائيه وذات دوافع سياسيه
وبان رئيس بايدن هو الاكثر فسادا
اليوم شهدنا اكثر نهار فيه شر في تاريخ
بلادنا لم نرى يوما رئيسا سابقا يتعرض على
يد خصومه لما عشته اليوم كل هذا في خضم
الانتخابات والسباق الرئاسي هذا ما يسمى
بالتدخل في الانتخابات من اجل سرقتها
والاهم من ذلك انه اضطهاد سياسي واضح
في مسار سير العمليه القضائيه يتعين على
المدعين العامين اثبات قضيتهم ومواجهه
الفريق القانوني للترامب طبعا هنا يمكن ان
يطلب من ترامب بعد ذلك تقديم اعتراض على
المحاكمه
وسيحدد القاضي خلالها شروطا للافراج عنه
حيث ان العمليه القضائيه قد تمتد لفتره
طويله وهو ما يطرح تساؤلات حول امكانيه
ترشح ترامب للانتخابات خلف القضبان من
الناحيه القانونيه يمكنه ذلك الدستور
الامريكي لا يفرض سوى ثلاثه شروط للترشح
وهي ان يكون مواطنا امريكيا بالولاده وان
يبلغ من العمر اكثر من 35 عاما ومقيما في
البلاد مده 14 عاما على الاقل مساعد ترامب
السياسيه غير مهدده والايدانه لن تمنعه من
الترشح حتى وان سجن يمكنه الدخول الى
السباق الانتخابي ولن يكون سابقه في
الولايات المتحده ففي عام
1920 خاض المرشح ذو التيار الاشتراكيه
الانتخابات خلف القضبان ونال نحو مليون
صوت وهو ما يزيد عن ثلاثه في المئه من
اجمالي عدد المقترعين في ذلك الوقت
التاييد الجمهوري ايضا يلعب دورا مهما
فلقد كشف استطلاع
ان 81% من الناخبين الجمهوريين يرون بان
التهمه الموجهه لدونالد ترامب لها دوافع
سياسيه بحته هنا يجب ان نشير الى ان حملته
الانتخابيه جمعت نحو اربعه ملايين دولار
في الفتره التي تم توجيه تهى من جنائيه
وهو مؤشر واضح على زياده شعبيته
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا هذه الصور مباشره ايضا من جلسه
للبرلمان الاوروبي بمدينه تستاسبورغ
الفرنسيه وهي جلسه عامه حول التحضير
الاجتماع المجلس الاوروبي في الفتره من
التاسع والعشرين الى 30 مليون يونيو لعام
2023 ولا سيما ايضا في ضوء الخطوات
الاخيره نحو ابراهيم ميثاق للهجره
نشاطنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
الامم المتحده تقول ان 110 ملايين
وحرب اوكرانيا والسودان تفاقمان ازمه
اللاجئين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد ونعود لمتابعه
هذه الصور المباشره من اجازه البرلمان
اللبناني الجلسه الثانيه عشره لانتخاب
رئيس للجمهوريه حيث تحتدم المنافسه
مشاهدينا بين مرشح المعارضه والتيار
الوطني الحر الوزير السابق جهاد ازعور
وايضا مرشح الثنائي حزب الله وحركه امل
الوزير السابق سليمان فرنجيه
وليد البعريني
اسامه سعد
الى ملف السودان مشاهدينا شهران مره على
الصراع المسلح في هذا البلد وفي اخر ارقام
الضحايا كشفت نقابه اطباء السودان ان عدد
القتل المدنيين منذ بدايه منذ بدايه
الصراع يرتفع الى نحو 958 شخصا واضافت ان
جميع مستشفيات الجنينه بظهر فورد خارج
الخدمه وان الوضع كارثي جاء هذا في وقت
حذرت فيه العديد من المنظمات الانسانيه من
ان استماره الصراع في السودان يمكن ان
يتحول الى حرب اهليه واسعه النطاق مع
تزايد عدد المفقودين وايضا القتلى وتراجع
الخدمات الصحيه
ميدانيا افاد مراس العربيه بان طيران
الجيش السوداني قصف مواقع التابعه لدعم
السريع في مدينه الاوبيض بشمال كردوفان
بينما سمع دوي مضادات ارضيه وبحسب المصادر
دمرت ضربات اربعه مركزات للدعم السريع في
جبل عيسى وجبل كردفان من جهه اخرى
مشاهدينا تواصلت الاشتباكات المتقطعه بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في
مدينه نيالا وسمعت ايضا اصوات تبادل اطلاق
الرصاص من الجانبين في احياء عده
الى ذلك قال الامين العام الامم المتحده
عن توني غوتيريشن ان هناك تقارير تتحدث
تتحدث عن اعمال عنف واسعه النطاق وسقوط
ضحايا من جميع انحاء اقليم دارفور في
السودان ولا سيما في الجنينه بولايه غرب
دارفور وعبر غوتيرشي بيان صحفي عن القلق
الشديد بشان البعد العرقي المتزايد لاعمال
العنف وكذلك من التقارير عن العنف الجنسي
هذا وجد دا غوتريس دعوته للقوات المسلحه
السودانيه وقوات الدعم السريع لوقف القطاع
والالتزام بوقف دائم للاعمال العدائيه
هذا وحضرت العديد من المنظمات الانسانيه
من ان الثمار الصراع في السودان يمكن ان
يتحول الى حرب اهليه واسعه النطاق مع
تزايد عدد المفقودين وايضا القتلى وتراجع
الخدمات الصحيه تطورات الوضع الانساني
والاجتماعي في السودان مشاهدينا نتابعها
مع الزميل فارس صلواتي
اذا كما قلت احمد لطالما كانت ملفات
المفقودين من ضمن القضايا الشائكه
والمعقده التي ترافق كل نزاع حول العالم
حيث ان عمليه التقصي والبحث قد تستمر
لسنوات او عقود طويله دون فائده في
السودان تحديدا ومع تواصل الحرب بين
المكونين العسكريين تتلقى فرق البحث
التابعه للجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
اتصالات دائمه للابلاغ عن حالات فقدان
واختفاء لافراد في العائلات السودانيه
اللجنه قالت بانه لا توجد ارقام دقيقه
للمفقودين في السودان ذلك ان الجهات
الرسميه هي المخوله في تقديم المعلومات
والمعطيات الدقيقه حول اعداد المفقودين
الا ان ذلك ليس متاحا حاليا بسبب تواصل
القتال الذي خلف بدوره شللا كبيرا على
القطاع الصحي
تواجه صعوبات كبيره جدا في التشغيل الطبي
كل المستشفيات والمؤسسات اللي هي كانت
موجود فيها دعم سريع واتخذك سكنات ما زالت
خارج الخدمه خرابه الاربعين مستشفى اضف
لذلك ما زالت هنالك بعض الاعتدادات
المتاخره تمت في الاسبوع الماضي
من جهتها نقابه اطباء السودان قالت ان عدد
القتل المدنيين منذ بدايه الصراع ارتفع
الى نحو 958 شخصا واضافت ان جميع مستشفيات
الجنينه بدار فورد خارج الخدمه والوضع بات
كارثيا الارقام الامميه اكدت ايضا ان فرار
قرابه 200 الف شخص من السودان ونزوح حوالي
مليوني شخص بينهم اكثر من 476 الفا عبروا
الى دول الجوار وفق المنظمه الدوليه
للهجره التابعه للامم المتحده المتحدث
الاقليميه للجنه للجنه الدوليه للصليب
الاحمر ايمان طرابلسي قالت ان هناك
اشكاليات كبيره تواجه عمل اللجنه في
السودان ابرزها عدم قدره السلطات المحليه
والجهات الصحيه الرسميه على تسريع عمليه
التعرف على هويات الجثامين واضافت انه لا
يزال هناك
الكثير من الجيتامين مجهوله الهويه ما
يصعب عمليه التوثيق والتاكد منهيه
المفقودين
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا نقعد مره اخرى لمتابعه هذه
الصوره المباشره اذا من جلسه البرلمان
اللبناني الثاني عشر التي تعقد حاليا
لانتخاب رئيس للجمهوريه كما اشرنا
مشاهدينا هذه المنافسه محتدمه الان بين
مرشح المعارضه والتيار الوطني الحره
الوزير السابق ومرشح الثنائي حزب الله
وحركه امل الوزير السابق سليمان فرنجيه
العاب مشاهدينا معنا مراسله العربيه
غنوهيم اهلا بك من بيروت وماذا من ما الذي
يحدث فيها
حول التفاصيل هذه الجلسه
بدات هذه الجلسه كما كان متوقعا عند
الساعه الحاديه عشره صباحا بتوقيت بيروت
اللافت كان حضور جميع النواب وهذه هي
المره الاولى كان هناك اكتمل النصاب في
الجلسه الافتتاحيه في لدى اول جلسه
لانتخاب رئيس للجمهوريه وهذه المره
الثانيه التي يكتمل فيها عدد النواب وهو
وهذا دليل على احتدام المعركه اليوم هذه
الجلسه لا تشبه سابقاتها ايضا لانها اول
مره يكون فيها معركه رئاسيه حقيقيه بين
بين مرشحين الواحد الاول تابع
لتيارات مسيحيه
مختلفه بينهم ايضا التيار الوطني الحر
اضافه الى التغيريين وعدد من النواب
المستقلين
والحزب والحزب الاشتراكي هناك يعني اجتماع
على اجماع على الوزير السابق جهاد الزعور
بمقابل مرشح الثنائي الشيعي الوزير السابق
سليمان الفرنجيه طبعا هذه يعني هناك انتهى
قبل قليل انتهى
انتهى التصويت وسيبدا الان بفرز الاصوات
لنعلم ما اذا كان بالفعل جهاد ازعور سيحقق
رقم قريب من ال 65 او يتعدى ال 65 وبهذا
يكون المرشح الاول الذي حصل على هذه
النسبه النسبه الكبيره ايضا اريد ان اقول
بان هذه المره الاولى التي يكون فيها
معركه حقيقيه بين مرشحين بعد يعني المراه
الاخيره كانت في العام 79 عندما كان هناك
فرنجيه الجد واليسر كيس وايضا حينها فاز
بالنصف زائد بالنصف زائد واحد اليوم في
حال كان هناك دوره ثانيه وهو امر مستبعد
كان يمكن للوزير السابق جهاد ازعور ايضا
ان يفوز بعدد الاصوات التي تفوق ال 65
بالدوره الاولى بطبيعه الحال هو بحاجه
ل 86 صوت وهو الثلثين وهو امر مستبعد
اخبار
بان حزب الله حركه امل سيعطلان النصاب
اليوم في الدور الثاني من الاقتراع غنوه
مره كان هناك تعطيل للدوره الثانيه عاده
ينسحب النواب من الدوره من الدوره الثانيه
ولكن الانسحاب اليوم من الدوره الثانيه
يعني بطبيعه الحال خاصه الا ان المرشح
جهاد اسعود يقترب من العدد المطلوب
للفوز بمنصب رئاسه الجمهوريه هناك بعض
النواب الذين قالوا بانهم في الدوره
الاولى سيكون تصفيتهم لي ورقه بيضاء ولكن
في حال كان هناك دوره ثانيه سيكون صوتهم
لجهاد ازعور هذا يعني مزيد من الاصوات
لجهاد الزعور ولكن كما ذكرت سيكون هناك
انسحاب وتعطيل لنصاب لنصاب الجلسه الثانيه
ايضا حزب الله وحركه امل الثنائي الشيعي
يعملان على تقليص يعملان على تقليص الفارق
كان هناك كلمه يعني لرئيس التيار الوطني
الحر جبران باسيل طالب فيه حزب حزب الله
بعدم التدخل بشؤون الطياره الداخليه خاصه
نحن نعلم ان هناك خمس نواب لا يصوتون
لجهاد ازعور كما طالب رئيس التيار الوطني
الحر ايضا هناك نواب
سيصوتون ربما لمشروع او عبر ورقه بيضاء
كان ايضا يحاول خاصه نواب الشمال قد يحاول
حزب الله من اجل تقليص الفارق لانه احنا
نتحدث عن 44 صوت لسليمان فرنجيه بحسب
الاصوات المتوقعه وهذا سيكون وهذا يعني
فرق كبير بينه وبين
الوزير الصادق جهاد ازعور وهذا يعني حتى
وان لم يكن هناك انتخاب لرئيس الجمهوريه
هذه ضربه
للثنائي الشيعي نحن سنلقي علينا معك على
اي تفاصيل جديده حول ما يجري في البرلمان
اللبناني شكرا لك من بيروت على مراسله
العربيه غنوه تحيات غنوه
[موسيقى]
بالعوده الى الملف السوداني مشاهدينا
اعلنت المفوضيه الساميه للامم المتحده
لشؤون اللاجئين ان نحو 110 ملايين
والاضطهاد او انتهاكات حقوقهم الانسانيه
وقال المفوض السامي المتحده لشؤون
اللاجئين
الذي تسبب في نزوح قرابه
في قائمه طويله من الازمات التي ادت الى
هذا العدد القياسي مشاهدينا من الخرطوم
ينضم الينا هاتفيا دكتور عطيه عبد الله
عطيه سكر نقابه اطباء السودان اهلا بك
دكتور عطيه معنا في هذه الساعه الاخباريه
يعني كما تابعنا نداءات الانسانيه تتوالى
وتتعالى ايضا اصواتها من داخل السودان ومن
خارجها ايضا من المنظمات الدوليه المعنيه
بحقوق الانسان وبشان الانساني ما الذي
يمكن ان تخبرنا به عن حقيقه الوضع
الانساني في السودان حاليا في مناطق
النزاع تحديدا
مرحبا بكم في البلده خلصت التعازي
الجماهير الشعب السوداني يوميات الصحه
والعافيه لكل الجرحى والمرضى وعوده
الحميده لكل المفقودين
نعم للاسف الشديد الوضعي يزداد سوءا يوما
بعد يوم يعني حتى ازدياد رقعه العمليات
العسكريه وما تخلفهم من ضحايا مدنيين
يزداد بالامس كانت ولايه جنوب دارفور امنه
لفتره معقده وبعد ذلك بمسائل الامس
ازدادت فيها
الاشتباكات بين الطرفين ايضا هنالك في
ولايه شمال دارفور وايضا وقبلها في
الخرطوم كل ذلك يعني تستعير هذه الحرب بين
الطرفي النزاع ولكن في نفس التوقيت لا
توجد ممرات امنه تمكن الطواقم الطبيه في
اداء عملها عدم وجود الممرات الطبيه ينعكس
تماما على نقص النقص الحاد في الكوادر
الطبيه والمستهلكات الطبيه وايضا يعني
يشكل عقبه اساسيه في توصيل المعينات
تفاصيل الكوادر الطبيه لهذه المستشفيات
الذي تعاني من نقص ونقص حاد جدا يعني عدد
من المستشفيات العامله هذه المستشفيات
اعدادها تتناقض وخدماتها تتناقص ايضا في
هذه الظروف
الانيه السيئه للغايه ايضا من جانب اخر هو
استهداف الكوادر الطبيه حتى الان وصلنا
الى للاسف الشديد يعني اكثر من 21 شهيدا
الطبيه
وايضا يعني اعتقال الاطباء وايضا اعتقال
يعني
فقدان الاطباء الذين لا نعلم عنهم اي شيء
كما ذكر
الدكتور عطيه من الطرف الذي يستهدف
الاطباء في السودان
الجهات العدليه المناط بها تحقيق وتقديم
الجهه الاجرمت في حق الكوادر الطبيه وايضا
هجرت في حق الشعب السوداني هذه جرائم حرب
لا يمكن
تحديدها الان ولا يمكننا نحن ايضا لانه
مهمتنا هي انسانيه
ومقصوره فقط على مهام محدده ولكن هذه
الجزئيه التي تلي تلي الجرائم ضد
الانسانيه والجرائم الحرب لها يعني
يمثلوها ولها من ينفذها ما يهمنا الان هو
توصيل هذه المعينات الطبيه الى المستشفيات
ما يهمنا الان هو يعني فتح هذه الممرات
الامنه لتوصيل المعينات الطبيه للمستشفيات
ما يهمنا حمايه الكوادر الطبيه ما يهمنا
ايضا عدم استهداف الكوادر الطبيه من اي
طرف لانه الخاسر الاوحد هو الشعب السوداني
لذلك نحن ومنذ اليوم الاول قلنا غالي
الحرب
طالبين
النزاع فورا ومن دون وصل الان الوطني احنا
مقب
لين على
عرف
يتم
الاستعبا
من الاستعدادات التي يجب ان تكون الان هي
بدات او انتهت بالتاكيد قبل وصول الفصل
الخريف نعم طيب
اهم الوقت شكرا لك من الخرطوم كنت معنا
هاتفي الدكتور عطيه عبد الله عطيه سكرتير
نقابه اطباء شكرا جزيلا لك
قالت وسائل الاعلام السوريه رسميه ان جندي
سوري اصيب بجروح خطيره فجر اليوم جراء قصف
جوي اسرائيلي استهدف نقاطا قرب العاصمه
دمشق حيث كشفت وكاله الانباء السوريه ان
اسرائيل استهدفت بعض النقاط جنوب غرب دمشق
مشيره الى سماع دوري انفجارات في محيط
العاصمه وكانت الانباء السوريه مشاهدين
قالت ايضا ان القصف تسبب بوقوع خسائر
ماديه مؤكده ان الدفاعات الجويه السوريه
تصدت لبعض الصواريخ الاسرائيليه من جهته
افاد المرصد السوري لحقوقه الانسان بان
القصف طال مستودعات سلاح تابعه لمقاتلينا
موالين لايران وان نيران اندلعت فيها ايضا
تفاهم محتمل بين واشنطن وطهران بشان
برنامج ايران النووي امر اكده رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بداماهو امام لجنه
العلاقات الخارجيه والامن في الكنيسه
الاسرائيلي وفقا لموقع اكسيس حيث نقل
الموقع عن مصادره من داخل الكنيست ان
نتنياهو اكد ان التفاهم بين الولايات
المتحده وايران بشان برنامج طيران النووي
امر ممكن مشيرا الى ان نتنياهو قال ان
اداره الرئيس الامريكي اجرت محادثات غير
مباشره مع ايران حول اتفاقيه تتعلق
بالبرنامج النووي الايراني
مشاهدينا اكد ايضا ان رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي شدد على ان بلاده ستعارض هذا
الاتفاق ولن تلتزم به من جهه اخرى كانت
واشنطن نفت دخولها في محادثات غير مباشره
مع ايران فيما يتعلق بالبرنامج النووي
افادت وسائل اعلام رسميه بان وزير
الخارجيه الصيني ابلغ وزير خارجي الامريكي
في اتصال هاتفي بانه يتعين على الولايات
المتحده التوقف عن التدخل في شؤون البلاد
ونقل تلفزيون الصين المركزي عن شين القول
خلال الاتصال ان على الولايات المتحده ان
تراعي الشوارع الاساسيه للصين مثل قضيه
تايوان
في حادث نادر في اليابان فتح احد الجنود
النار على زملائهما ادى الى مقتل جنديين
واصابه اخرين فيما تم القاء القبض على
المشتبه به وهو عنصر من قوه دفاع ذاتي
بميدان عسكري للرمايه في مقاطعه جيفو بوسط
البلاد واوضحت قوه دفاع الذات البريه في
بيان انه وخلال تدريب برصاص الحي في اطار
تمرين عدد من الافراد الجدد اطلق احدهم
النار على ثلاثه من العاملين ومن جهته ذكر
المتحدث باسم الحكومه
ذكر ان مشتبها به اعتقل لكنه لم يذكر
تفاصيل اخرى واظهرت لقطه جويه بثتها
المحطه العسكريه
المحطه عفوا اظهرت عسكريين ومدنيين
يتجمعون حول مركبه الطوارئ والشرطه تغلق
طرقا قريبه
قانون الذكاء الاصطناعي مشاهدينا على
طاوله البرلمان الاوروبي حيث من المقرر ان
يناقش اعضاء البرلمان مسوده مشروع القانون
في حين سيتم تصويت خلال الفتره من 12 الى
الخامس عشر من يونيو مع ضروره ان تحصل
المسوده على موافقه البرلمان باكمله
لاقارها هذا وكان البرلمان الاوروبي ناقش
في جلسته المنعقده منتصف الشهر الماضي
اقرار القانون الاولي في العالم للذكاء
الاصطناعي والذي من شانه ان يحضر استخدام
اكثر التكنولوجيا متطوره ضررا مثل تشارجي
حيث يهدف البرلمان من قانون الذكاء
الاصطناعي وضع قواعد تعزز شفافيه والاداره
الفعاله لمخاطر انظمه الذكاء الاصطناعي
خصوصا تلك التي تشكل مستوى غير مقبول من
المخاطر على السلامه العامه بشكل صريح
وكما تابعنا قبل المشاهدين بدات قبل قليل
جسده البرلمان اللبناني هذه الجلسه
الثانيه عشره لانتخاب رئيس للجمهوريه حيث
تحتدم المنافسه بين مرشح المعارضه والتيار
الوطني الحر الوزير السابق جهاد ازعور
ومرشح الثنائي حزب الله وحركه امل الوزير
السابق سليمان فرنجيه ويتوقع ان ينال
المرشح ازعور نتيجه قريبه لستين صوتا وهو
ما يرجح اكتمال نصاب الدوره الاولى دون
النجاح في الحصول على ثلثي الاصوات
المطلوبه لانتخاب الرئيس وهي سته وثمانون
صوتا على ان ينسحب الثنائي حركه امل وحزب
الله ومن يدعمهم من الدوره الثانيه لكي
تفقد الجلسه نصابها علما انه في الدوره
الثانيه يحتاج المرشح الى النصف زائد واحد
من الاصوات للفوز برئاسه الجمهوريه
جهاد ازعور
افادت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه بمقتل
الفلسطيني برصاص الجيش الاسرائيلي في مخيم
بلاطه في مدينه نابلس الشماليه الضفه
الغربيه في الجيش الاسرائيلي ان خمسه
اسرائيليين اصيبوا في حادثه اطلاق نار
منفصل قرب جنين بينهم اربعه جنود هذا
وكانت قوه من الجيش الاسرائيلي داهمت مخيم
بلاطه وحاصرت منزلا وفق ما قال شهود عيان
من داخل المخيم لوكاله مؤكدين اندلاع
اشتباكات مسلحه عنيفه بداخله
تشهد اسعار الاجهزه الكهربائيه في مصر
ارتفاع قياسيا مع نظره في العرض ادخلت
العديد من المصريين خصوصا المقبلين على
الزواج في رحله بحث شاقه لاقتناء هذه
الاجهزه وتلبيه متطلبات البيت الجديد
ويرجع مختصون هذا الوضع الى تفاقم الازمه
الاقتصاديه في مصر نتيجه ارتفاع اسعار
الدولار نتابع
شراء الاجهزه الكهربائيه يتحملها والد
العروس في مصر بحسب العادات والتقاليد روى
لنا صابر عبد الفتاح عن معاناته قبل زفاف
ابنته في رحله البحث عن الاجهزه التي اصبح
الكثير منها الان اما غير متوفر او يباع
باسعار مرتفعه تتزايد يوميا بعد صعب جدا
واللي عنده بنت بيجهزها بقت مشكله بالنسبه
له
يعني مشكله جامده يعني انا كنت ناوي اجيب
الاجهزه الكهربائيه كلها مره واحده دلوقتي
هجيب على الاقل نص الاجهزه انا بتكلم
دلوقتي في بعض الاجهزه داخله في 60 الف
جنيه الاثار السلبيه للحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه وارتفاع الاسعار عالميا فاقم
ازمه الدولار التي ادت الى ارتفاع غير
مسبوق في الاسعار بعد تخفيض قيمه الجني
اكثر من مره ومنذ مارس من العام الماضي
فرضت الحكومه قيودا على الاستيراد لتقليل
استنزاف العمله الاجنبيه ما ادى الى تناقص
الاجهزه الكهربائيه في الاسواق سواء
المستورده او المنتجه محليا وتعتمد على
مكون اجنبي في التصنيع هذا النقص ادى الى
ظهور سوق سوداء للاجهزه واستغلال من بعض
التجار بمضاعفه الاسعار
الرسمي ما ينفعش ان انا اطلعه اكتر من
فاتوره الضريبيه بسعره الرسمي لكن المشكله
مثلا في تاجر مثلا محطوط في منطقه مثلا
معزوله مش مسجل مش مش بيلم البضاعه من
السوق وبيروح يبدا يبيع بسعره وهو عايزه
الرقابه موجوده الرقابه ما بتبقاش موجوده
على اللي مش مكشوف حركه البيع الاول كانت
شغاله بسبب المنتجات الكتير دلوقتي قلت
منتجات وقالت حركه البيع بسبب زياده
الاسعار طبعا انت كل يوم في تغيير اسعار
المصانع خفضت طاقتها الانتاجيه بسبب نقص
مكونات التصنيع المستورده ما ادى الى
انخفاض المعروض وبرغم الافراج الجمركي عن
البضائع المكدسه في الموانئ منذ يناير
الماضي بقيمه نحو ثلاثه وعشرين مليار
دولار الا ان الاولويه منحت للسلع
الاساسيه والادويه وبعض مستلزمات الانتاج
من ضمن الحلول
المقترحه ان يسيبوا الناس تدبر دولار
لمعرفتهم لكن ده للاسف نتيجته انه هيرفع
سعر الدولار في السوق السوداء اللي الحل
التاني هو حل طويل الاجل ان البلد تبتدي
بمبادرات انها تصنع كل ما يتم استيراده
احنا ابتدينا فعلا او في مبادرات رئاسيه
اللي هي مبادره ابدا بدات في القصه دي لكن
عشان يطلع نتيجه للكلام ده احنا قدامنا
سنوات اه ما بين توفير الدولار واستقرار
سعر الصرف يبقى الحل طويل الامد الذي بدات
بوادره بمبادرات عبر التوسع في استخدام
المكونات المحليه في التصنيع راندا ابو
العزم العربيه القاهره
مشاهدينا تراجع الدولار قرب ادنى مستوى في
ثلاثه اسابيع امام اليورو وقرب ادنى مستوى
في شهر مقابل الجنيه الاسترليني بعد ان
رسخت بياناته تضخم اقل من المتوقع وجهه
النظر التي ترجح المركزي الامريكي ان
المركزي الامريكي سيمتنع عن رفع سعر
الفائده هذه المره عندما يصدر يصدر قراره
في وقت لاحق من اليوم حول الرهانات على
وقف المركز الامريكي لرفع الفائده
مشاهدينا اللبناني وتابعنا قبل قليل في
الاخبار العاجله ما نقله مراسل نقلته
مراسل العربي عن ان البرلمان اللبنانيه في
انتخاب رئيس الجمهوريه من الجوله الاولى
وفشل الفرنجيه وازعر في الحصول على
الاصوات اللازمه للفوز بالرئاسه اللبنانيه
ومعنى مراسل العربيه
[موسيقى]
لن تقدم ولن تؤخر المتوقع الان ان يبدا
النواب بالخروج من من الجلسه من مجلس
النواب عن مدخل مجلس النواب لانه لن يكون
هناك دوره ثانيه كما هو متوقع بالطبع يعني
هذه هذه الارقام تمكن يعني تمكن من تقليص
كان هناك امكانيه من تقليص الفارق كما
ذكرت كان هناك نواب يبدو ان نواب التيار
الوطني اهل الحر لم يلتزموا جميعهم
بالتسميه لجهاد ازعور بعد النواب الذين
كانوا قد تحدثوا عن اوراق بيضاء او عن
اسماء اخرى يبدو ايضا انه تمكن حزب الله
كما ذكرت ربما نواب الشمال تمكن حزب الله
من اقناعهم بالتصويت
[موسيقى]
في ذلك
الوقت شكرا لكم
مشاهدينا كشف شرطه ان ضحايا جرائم قتل
ارتكبها شخص في الحاديه والثلاثين من
العمر قيد الاعتقال هم طالب وطالبه في
التاسعه عشر من العمر ورجل خمسيني وقالت
الشرطه انها لا تبحث عن اي جنات اخرين
الخامسه والنصف صباحا بالتوقيت المحلي كان
شارع ملتا حيث اقف الان مسرحا لجريمه
مروعه حيث قام شخص يستقل حافله صغيره بدهس
عده اشخاص نقل ثلاثه منهم للمستشفى
لكن مدينه التي تبعد 130 ميلا شمال غربي
لندن كانت مسرحا لعمليه الطعن الساعه
الرابعه فجرا في شارع الكستن الذي يبعد
كيلومترين فقط عن هنا بعد ذلك اصبح شارع
مجدله مسرحا لجريمه اخرى حيث وجدت جثه في
الشارع
انا على بعد 25 ثانيه مشيا عن المكان الذي
وقعت فيه احدى الجرائم اشعر بحجم تغطيه
الاعلاميه والرجال الشرطه الامر كان مرعبا
بالنسبه الي
انه لا امر مروع
حق لست
في صدمه كبيره لكننا ما زلنا ناتي الى وسط
المدينه ولم نفهم ما حدث حتى الان
ثلاثه قتلى وثلاثه جرحى ومعتقل لدى شرطه
عمره 31 عاما محصله صباح جنوني شهدت فيه
نوتينغام ثلاثه حوادث امنيه متزامنه الطوق
الامني هذا حصر سته شوارع على الاقل واوقف
خدمه ترامب لساعات طويله
الشرطه المحليه ووحده مكافحه الارهاب
وقوات امنيه مسلحه ومقنعه في مشهد قل
نظيره في شوارع بريطانيا احتلت شوارع
مدينه نوتنجم لساعات طويله اضافه الى
عشرات من سيارات الطوارئ والاطفاء كل
التفصيل مهم في هذه التحقيقات الضخمه من
كاميرات المراقبه في الشوارع الى استجواب
المعتقل حتى مداهمات عده نفذتها الشرطه
المحليه فيما حبست المدينه انفسها خوفا من
هجمه اخرى من مسرح الجريمه في مصطفى زارو
العربيه
قصص جديده بدات تتكشف على رحله ضياع اربعه
اطفال كولومبيين في الغابه لاربعين يوما
بعد تحطم طائره كانوا يستقلونها وموتى
والدتهم من هذه القصص حديث الاطفال عن ان
الام كانت على قيد الحياه لمده اربعه ايام
وهي التي طلبت منهم مغادره مكان تحطم
الطائره وان كلب ظل لايام يرعاهم قبل ان
يختفي في الغابه نتابع
اول صوره للاطفال الناجين بعد انقاذهم من
الضياع اربعين يوما في الغابه الموحشه
اعطي الاطفال دفترا والوانا فرسموا ويلسون
كلب بوليسي قال الاطفال انه رافقهم في
الغابه لايام قبل ان يختفي عن الانظار
وسائل الاعلام وصفحات التواصل في كولومبيا
تتحدث اليوم عن بطوله الكلب ويلسون
[موسيقى]
فقدت اثار الكلب المدرب في بدايه ايام
البحث ويبدو انه عثر على الاطفال اولا
حرسهم لايام ثم ذهب لطلب النجده لكنه ضاع
في الغابه
في البدايه كان الكلب معهم مشوا وعدا
الكلب اليهم وهكذا ولكن في وقت لاحق اختفى
الكلب سالتهم ماذا فعلوا عندما هطل المطر
فقالوا انهم اخذوا اغصانا واوراقا كبيرا
واحتموا تحتها
بطله اخرى فقدت حياتها في سبيل نجاه
الاطفال امهم مجدلين تبين انها كانت على
قيد الحياه لمده اربعه ايام قبل ان تلفظ
انفاسها الاخيره وهي من زود الاطفال بدقيق
الكاس فلياكلوه ومعدات اخرى ابقتهم على
قيد الحياه
كان لدى الفتاه مهارات البقاء على قيد
الحياه الشيء الوحيد الذي اوضحته ليزي
الطفله التي عمرها 13 عاما هو ان والدتها
كانت على قيد الحياه لمده اربعه ايام وهي
التي طلبت منهم مغادره المكان
العنايه الالهيه وحدها من انقذ الاطفال
التائين من مخالب النمور المتوحشه
والافاعي السامه والحشرات القاتله التي
تنتشر في هذه الغابات المطريه قصه النجاه
ستكون مصدر الهام لمخرجي الافلام وصناع
السينما ولكن قبل ذلك على الحكومه ان تفصل
الان في معركه حضانه الاطفال التي بدات
تظهر بين اقاربهم بعد ان صاروا حديث
العالم
الاخباريه مشاهدينا نذكر بالعناوين
[موسيقى]
قدسها تحت القصف الروسي وبيلاروسيا تتسلم
اسلحه النوويه تكتيكيه من موسكو
ترامب يعتبر محاكمتهم محاوله لسرقه
الانتخابات المقبله ويتهم بايدن بالفساد
في تواصل امريكي الصيني تحمل واشنطن
مسؤوليه تدهور العلاقات
نهايه المشاهدين فيها امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات